aucun poison découvert dans le centre
alexeï navalni c'est ce qu'affirment les
médecins de l'hôpital d'omsk où
l'opposant russe est hospitalisé en
réanimation en sibérie après avoir fait
un malaise il est toujours dans un état
instable c'est ce que précise les
médecins est-ce qu'ils ne permettraient
pas son transfert à l'étranger malgré
l'arrivée à omsk d'un avion médicalisé
allemand écoutez le médecin chef adjoint
de l'hôpital sur place je peux vous dire
que la nuit s'est bien passée
vers 8 heures du matin son état s'est
amélioré nous ne sommes néanmoins pas
parvenus à une stabilisation cuillère de
son état y compris du point de vue
hémodynamique aujourd'hui s'est tenu un
conseil des médecins avec la
participation de nombreux spécialistes
c'est sûr que j'ai reçu de notre
laboratoire de chimie et de toxicologie
les résultats de tous les tests
effectués pour vérifier la présente
certaines substances sont négatives
les tests de dépistage sont toujours en
cours cela prendra environ deux jours
de quelle substance s'agit-il
je ne peux pas vous le dire